because I think one other series that I
watched that just hit like really deep
is this for like for episode ova based
on this novel called
no longer human which is like a classic
Japanese I all summer yeah yeah yeah
that is like it's probably one of the
most harrowing things that I've watched
never heard about that what is it right
what it's written by this guy called
docile summer who is consider like one
of the three greats okay
traditional Japanese literature he was
like a guy for the big three what's the
story on this one um it's like it's been
a while since I've watched it but I'm
not sure if it's his like water
biography or if it's like based on his
life story but it's just a stone his
lifestyle okay so it's just based on
this life story about this guy who just
who just keeps taking Elle's now like
imagine if you just take imagine if you
just take elves your entire life and
you're just looking for that one win but
no you just you just you just keep
taking LS your entire life and dangle
sounds like the Joker it's it's this guy
just gets more and more depressed as his
life goes on because to it is based on
his life story so like this character
it's someone who's like clinically
depressed and he's so depressed that's
you know he tries taking his life
multiple times I were with with you know
woman that he's been with or just people
that he finds and then he just he just
keeps living which which is actually
true like the author tried committing
suicide or several times and then he
succeeded yeah he actually succeeded so
that's round himself yeah so that's like
the headspace of the author who wrote
this and like it's it's this the stories
like I can't wait so he died yeah yeah
he finished after finishing this store
after he finished this was the last
novel here oh yeah
yeah so it's just [ __ ] it's the most
like it's like one long suicide no then
yeah yeah yes because it's just like a
roll peek into the headspace of someone
who's almost depressing absolutely
it's a really good piece yeah because
like it's it's it's just this it's just
based on his life story
shitty things that happens to him and
then it ends with just you think that
you think he's found like of this ray of
hope right you think you think he's you
think he's found his ray of hope and
then he just gets [ __ ] on once again
like imagine if someone has stage-four
leukemia and then you just find out he
has AIDS as well and then he gets kicked
on and then you just kick on it kick him
while he's going yeah and like how it
ends is that he's like he's like so like
he he doesn't even think that dot like
if he commits suicide that's not even
the right way to end it it's called no
longer human because he feels like he's
so he's so low that he just doesn't he's
no longer human like he he's no he no
he's no longer is in this human world
and it is the most harrowing thing I've
used harrowing a lot because I don't
know I don't know why it means the only
way to describe the code I don't know
who you're essentially reading the
default right yeah yeah and that's that
sounds like yeah yeah it's it's brutal
it's the only way to describe it
I mean I I like those experiences but
they are like you said over there you
have to be in the right headspace
because I feel like if you go into it
like already like pretty [ __ ] up like
you're not feeling too great it's
talking to do great for your mental
health
I think the one problem as well with no
longer human and the reason why probably
not a lot of people like know about it
yeah is that not just because of its
like subject matter but just the fact
that anime fans today know does I or
some movie for that one boom go stray
dogs character like a people like oh
does I yeah he's my husband Oh in bingo
stray dogs not knowing that the real
does I was the most depressed [ __ ]
over in like all of Japanese literature
and he wrote some not just no longer
human but he brought some amazing pieces
of literature yeah just because again he
based it so much on his real life and
the fact that he was just [ __ ]
depressed as hell yeah and is like I
feel like you have to be in the
headspace to write something that
powerful is that raw that just hits and
just cuts that deeply it's like an Edgar
Allan Poe situation yeah you can you
can't write dark poetry like that unless
you had a [ __ ] up life
knob so yeah I feel spoiled I've never
hit worry about sorry sorry to bring a
downer of this episode people watch